welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid have you ever noticed how weird
things feel when you accelerate if
you're in a car moving along the road at
a steady speed then everything feels
normal as far as your senses are
concerned you're sitting still and
everything else is moving around you the
only reason you know you're moving is
because you've learned that things like
trees and houses don't your wisdom
brings you to that conclusion not your
senses it's what we call an inertial
reference frame or IRF in contrast let's
say you're sitting at a red light with a
hanging pendulum what you don't have a
pendulum hanging in your car weirdo as
you accelerate forward the pendulum
moves toward the back of the car so it
seems to someone sitting in the car
there must be a force it's an illusion
it's what we call a fictitious force or
a force that's only there when you're
looking from a certain perspective in
this case the perspective is inside an
accelerating car what you might call an
accelerated reference frame or a RF
things get a little more interesting
when you're traveling in a circle
rotation even at constant speed is
always accelerated so let's have some
fun with it
this is a merry-go-round it took me a
while to find one of these apparently
they've been removing them for child
safety or something there are newer ones
that meet safety regulations but they're
really expensive and they look stupid
too I mean at some point you have to let
kids make mistakes some of the best
stuff in life can cause temporary pain
anyway a spinning merry-go-round is an
accelerated perspective if you're off of
it it's clear that it's the
merry-go-round that's spinning if you're
on it it looks like everything else is
spinning around you but things feel a
little strange so let's bring that
pendulum back for a moment sitting on
the spinning merry-go-round the pendulum
appears to swing outward away from the
center so from this perspective it would
look like you need a force on the
pendulum pointing away from the center
this force is what we call a centrifugal
force or sometimes mispronounced
centrifugal force its fictitious it's an
illusion you only feel like you need it
because there doesn't appear to be any
other reason for what you're seeing
standing on the ground though you get a
different perspective the pendulum is
accelerating in a circle so the outward
centrifugal force is completely
unnecessary
what does exist from both perspectives
is the tension in the string that's a
real force and it has two components
part of it is balancing the weight of
the pendulum the other part is causing
its acceleration toward the center this
Center seeking force is sometimes called
a centripetal force and it's the net
force toward the center net force is
found using Newton's second law the
total force toward the center equals
mass times acceleration or in this case
mass times rotational speed twice times
your distance from the center it's
stronger when the merry-go-round spins
faster or when you're further from the
center since it's only a net force it
could be made of an entire single force
like the gravity on the moon from the
earth a part of a force like the
pendulum on the merry-go-round or
multiple forces together like cars
experienced on a circular ramp the
fictitious centrifugal force has the
same strength opposite direction and
only exists in the rotating frame on the
merry-go-round off the merry-go-round on
off on off on off get the picture but
when I'm on one I can feel the outward
force actually that's not what you're
feeling feeling something might make it
a real experience but that doesn't make
it a Fizz
chol reality the merry-go-round exerts
some friction on my butt to maintain
circular motion otherwise I would just
slide right off according to Newton's
third law my butt responds by exerting a
friction force back on the
merry-go-round what you feel is your
response to the force not the force
itself perceptions kind of tricky like
that for this reason if it all possible
you should try to work from your
perspective with no acceleration at all
so what do you think about them removing
all those merry-go-rounds please rant in
the comments whatever your opinion and
until next time remember it's okay to be
a little crazy